moon over mainhattan die längste
mondfinsternis des jahrhunderts lockte
am freitagabend in frankfurt zahlreiche
menschen auf straßen und dachterrassen
bei einbruch der dämmerung zog der
erdtrabant doch etwas versteckt durch
die abend wolken hin
die rötliche färbung des sogenannten
blut mondes war aber trotzdem gut zu
erkennen
die schaulustigen die dm in gehen und
live ebeling freuten sich an ihrem
aussichtspunkt über ein paar schöne
impressionen
es war also allgemein hier sehr sehr
voll aber der erst einmal zum mond ist
wirklich sehr sehr schön es ist auch
sehr schön rot geworden aber leider noch
nicht so richtig teuer und das ist
schade ich habe eindruck ist man hier
oben sowieso von der aussicht und wenn
er jetzt gleich richtig zum vorschein
kommen ich glaube dann gibt es ein
richtig schönes panorama etwas in geduld
üben mussten sich auch die menschen in
berlin in der bundeshauptstadt zeigte
der mond ebenfalls seine wahre pracht
erst als es schon richtig dunkel war
eine mondfinsternis tritt auf wenn bei
vollmond sonne mond und erde in einer
linie stehen
diesmal stand der erdtrabant mehr als
100 minuten lang komplett im schatten
unseres planeten